welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Thor love and thunder will
break the Marvel world as the first
fourth MCU solo film following a single
character breaking us free from the
trilogy plus team up pattern that we saw
with Iron Man with Captain with
Spider-Man now sure Thor Ragnarok
represented a sort of reset for the
character but if this is truly a fresh
start for Thor why is the God of Thunder
facing the ghosts of his past like his
ex Jane Foster his broken Hammer mjolnir
well the truth is that Marvel had Kevin
feige has never really cared about the
trilogy structure and is instead allowed
his character's natural trajectories to
chart their paths was Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness a sequel to
the 2016 Doctor Strange are really a
sequel to Avengers Infinity war or a
sequel to one division does it even
matter all of these characters just leap
from title to title to face whatever
demons they discover along the way and
in Thor's case despite what seemed like
an insane tonal shift between Thor the
Dark World and Ragnarok the reason
Jane's return now feels like a natural
logical move for the God of Thunder is
because that God of Thunder has always
been a broken unworthy loser and that's
why we always love him as he is trying
to win the affection of whoever whether
it's Jane Foster Valkyrie and now
Star-Lord he is a loser with a perennial
broken heart and so despite Jane being
out of sight out of mind we always want
to see these two reunited so let's break
down the real reason for that Thor's
unworthiness in this next episode of our
series feige's plan why Thor was never
worthy now initially Kevin feige gave a
lot of latitude to the creative teams
behind the first two Thor films to
express their unique Vision to the
character Kenneth Branagh introduced
Thor in a Shakespearean tale about Royal
Duty and betrayal in Thor the Dark World
director Alan Taylor brought in the
scope to distant Realms and their
intersection with astrophysics must I
forget the first mention of the term 616
universe that was finally just codified
in Multiverse of Madness now of course
Thor the Dark World has a reputation as
the MCU film fans might have connected
the least with perhaps due to the 35
days of reshoots that Kevin feige cited
in the awkward dubbed audio the studio
forced in to set up the ether as an
infinity stone ignoring its phase of
matter but during these experimental
early phases Thor really just struggled
to find his place in The Avengers he
wasn't the prototypical leader or the
smart ass or the muscle or the tortured
Soul he was just a God and often while
these Ensemble crises unfolded Thor was
just kind of sequestered on an odd
mythological side quest like cave
bathing or acts forging But ultimately
Thor's strongest contributions were the
looser more comedic beats I've care how
you speak
low-key is beyond reason but he is about
God and he's my brother he killed 80
people in two days
adopted
foreign
cap
[Music]
nothing ah and that last example was the
Breakthrough moment Chris Hemsworth
hardly saying anything conveys total
existential panic over someone else
matching his sacred worthiness robbing
him of his one supposed unique advantage
over the others we actually learn an
endgame how cap in that moment was just
sparing Thor's Pride he truly could lift
that hammer yet by in-game Thor has been
so broken down that he no longer cares
about that precious worthiness and the
reason Thor was able to get to that
point is because Hemsworth in the studio
both recognize that what makes Thor
great in the MCU isn't his worthiness
and his pride it's his unworthiness and
his anxiety he is as unstable and is
temperamental as the hammer that he
wields mjolnir is the perfect metaphor
for his soul the most revelatory moments
throughout the franchise were centered
around his relationship with that hammer
from his failure to lift it in the 2011
film to his crisis of faith when hella
shatters it faith that was only restored
when his father's ghost quips are you
Soul the god of hammers of course Thor
is the God of Thunder but one could
argue The Institute Thor's best
qualities is that he is the God of this
Hammer the decision to shatter mjolnir
at the beginning of Ragnarok was a
pretty bold one only made after
Hemsworth and Kevin feige anti-cowatiti
decided to unleash Thor's broken Spirit
after each Voltron which is something
that Hemsworth revealed at Comic-Con in
2017. well I've played this character
five times but me personally I got a bit
more to myself and thought we gotta try
something different spoke with tiger
spoke with Kevin and all of us agreed if
we're going to make a third four we have
to really push the envelope and
experiment and take it to another level
so that was what this film was you know
um cut his hair broke his hammer change
his clothes change the world and I think
that's what you're going to see and be
excited about is something incredibly
unique and different for not only the
full world but the Marvel Universe
takeaway Titi gets a lot of credit for
Reinventing Thor in the MCU and he
deserves a lot of it but really his
successes in Ragnarok were the result of
him identifying the character's
strengths from previous movies his
Hammer anxiety his hometown hero
fixation his rivalry with Loki and
watiti built the Ragnarok film around
those qualities breaking his hammer
destroying his home and really taking
the second act of Thor the Dark World
where he and Loki teamed up on a fun
Quest and made that essentially the
entire Ragnarok film so again it has
never been about Thor's worthiness it's
been about his unworthiness ragnarok's
true success were a function of what TT
playing up for as a loser something
watiti has perfected in his comedic work
taking High status characters and
revealing them to be pathetic whether
they're powerful vampires puking up
blood on a bender or Hitler as a boy's
imaginary friend so in Ragnarok Thor
begins dumped by Jane he loses his
hammer he gets his head shaved like a
Biblical Samson he gets rejected by
Valkyrie he fights as a gladiator and
loses that bite and then gets his eye
knocked out and then failing to defeat
hella in the final battle must unleash
the foe that he defeated in the First
Act to allow that fire monster to
destroy his home Infinity war is a
better movie because Thor loses as he
fails to go for the head and the game is
a better movie for the way Thor's inner
anxieties finally matches external
appearance in the Bliss that we feel
when Thor finally admits that he's not
the only Avenger worthy of his hammer I
knew it and so with Thor love and
thunder unworthiness again seems to be
at the heart of it all as Thor for once
turns away from fights and gawks at the
woman who dumped him now wielding the
metaphor for his broken Soul while Titi
is of course adapting in the Jason Aaron
Mighty Thor and God of Thunder runs from
the comics in which Thor's conflict with
Gore the god butcher rattles his
worthiness so that he relinquishes the
hammer now I for one never thought we
would see Natalie Portman return to the
MCU but her return here is actually a
natural step because it forces Thor to
confront an anxiety from his past after
he had gone through all of these stages
of evolution in the Ragnarok era so her
return works because despite Thor's
growth he is proven unable to get over
Jane he brought her up in Ragnarok she
didn't dump me no I dumped her this is a
mutual dumping and then crying over her
and game oh you know Jane and I aren't
even dating anymore so Jane is a one
major broken piece of his past that this
broken mjolnir needs to reassemble
himself so she isn't the ill-bitting
love interest from an earlier era where
Marvel didn't know what it was doing all
along she has been
so will Thor finally be worthy of her
love I hope not as hell approved Thor is
more fun when he swiped left thank you
for joining us for episode 2 of this
exploration of Kevin feige's MCU
strategy follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos and follow me rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]